use everything you got they're not doing
it greg you know i i'm totally for this
uh going after the oil business and
everything but we're we're also at the
same time literally punishing russians
who hate putin more than anybody here
after kovid came from china any
criticism of china was perceived as
racist
when we kept having to tell everybody we
must separate government from the people
we should remind ourselves here to
separate the government from the people
we are punishing paralympians of all
people we're taking money from
hard-working people who want to feed
their kids and we're calling that
strategy but with china we called it
bigotry so i just want to point that out
but this is the result i mean when you
look at this when you look at the byte
administration you're seeing a clash
between
real world and old world and i would say
the modern world in the sense that right
now the bite administration
is designed by people who make college
brochures
right like every kind of person working
together sitting on the quad talking
about environmental justice and trans
issues and then you have the old world
putin invades ukraine right you what we
what america needs right now are adults
who have no patience for zoom classes on
pronouns that's what we are doing right
now we are we've seen it people are
discussing the right pronouns so right
now this is a game of who's going to
starve who right the russian army versus
ukrainian people the issue is putin
doesn't care who starves he doesn't even
care about the troops so this is what's
interesting is we don't understand this
we don't understand we understand
hashtags and memes we're inspired by
what we see on twitter he doesn't care
his legacy is going to outlast memes our
system transfers power every four to
eight years that doesn't allow for a
30-year plan or a 100-year plan putin
doesn't like his chances with x he'll
just wait for y that's what chyna did
they knew that they were thinking if
trump's not around we'll just wait for
the next guy so we've been spending all
these decades playing ping pong while
these guys are looking ahead playing
chess because they don't they just see
this stuff that's why they're so
ruthless about their own people they
don't care if they're if they're if
they're if their people are starving you
know we're living off a diet at cable
punditry and buzzfeed listicles
you know they don't
believe me does not care if the world
thinks he's a really mean girl right but
russia
does care and that's what we got to
figure out we got to figure out how to
get the persuasion to the russian people
because they've tasted our world they've
had our apple products right they love
our music they love our technology you
can't put the modern world back in the
genie bottle but you know the only way
we can do that or the only way you can
stop putin is to get the russian people
to to
to get rid of him because they don't
want to be north korea but that's where
they're going hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else